بالعوده الى الجدل بشان استخدام السلاح
النووي التكتيكي اثراء اعلاني موسكو عزمها
نشره بعض من الرؤوس في بيلاروسيا سلاح
نووي تكتيكي ما الذي يعنيه ذلك ما الفرق
بينه وبين السلاح النووي الذي اعتدنا
السماع عنه في المبدا الفرق يكمن في الحجم
وغرض الاستخدام ومكان الهدف بالنسبه للحجم
فان القدره التدميريه لاصغر راس تفجيري
لسلاح نووي تصل الى كيلو طن واحد او اقل
واكبرها 100 كيلو طن اما السلاح النووي
الاستراتيجي فقد تصل قوته التدميريه الى
الف كيلو
للتوضيح فان الكيلوتون ينتج قوه تدميريه
تعادل 1000 طن من ماده تي ان تي المتفجره
السلاح النووي التكتيكي مخصص للاستخدام في
ساحه المعركه او بتوجيه ضربه محدوده للعدو
دون التسبب في تداعيات اشعاعيه واسعه
النطاق بينما يستخدم السلاح الاستراتيجي
للمسافات البعيده ولضرب العمق ولكن من
يمتلك هذا السلاح
الولايات المتحده
بنحو 230 سلاح نوويا تكتيكيا نشرت جزء من
مخزونها في ايطاليا في تركيا في بلجيكا
وهولندا كذلك اما روسيا
تحدثت الاحصائيات عن نحو 2000 من هذه
الرؤوس النوويه التكتيكيه واخر الاخبار عن
نشر بعض منها في بيلاروسيا تحديدا
تبقى هناك باكستان والصين والهند واسرائيل
وكوريا الشماليه كل هذه الدول لديها انواع
متعدده من هذه الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
المقارنه بين التكتيك والاستراتيجي هي في
الحقيقه مقارنه بين الاسوا والاكثر سوءا
اذ يعتبر الخبراء ان كل تلك الاسلحه فتاكه
والهدف من استخدامها احداث تغيير
استراتيجي في اي مواجهه محتمله
القصف النووي الامريكي لهيروشيما ونجازاكي
في اليابان عامر 45 من القرن الماضي كان
بقبلتين نوويتين تكتيكيتين الاولى قوتها
التفجيريه نحو خمسه عشر الثانيه 21 كيلو
طن
القنبلتان الامريكيتان قتلت اكثر من 100
الف شخص فورا ومات عشرات الالاف لاحقا
بسبب الاشاعات
في محاكاه لصراع امريكيه الروسيه اجرتها
جامعه فلسطين في الولايات المتحده اظهرت
هذه الدراسه ان استخدام سلاح نووي تكتيكي
قد يخلف اكثر من 90 مليون قتيل ومصاب